[...]
All right.
Well, welcome to the introduction
to the command line tool.
Just curious,
how many people have used it before?
Okay, cool.
Yeah, so this will be a not very technical
kind of brief overview of the tool,
just to kind of give people an idea if
they think it would be useful for them.
And then we can go over
some questions and answers.
Yeah, and if you are, it seems like something
that you're interested in and would
like to use, happy to work with you on
any projects that you think
it might be useful for.
So I'm just going to, let me see.
All right, I'm going to share my screen.
All right.
Can you guys see that?
Okay.
All right.
So the I command line tool.
There we go.
So what is I a it's a command
line interface to archive.org.
So basically any service, archive.
org service or
API that you want to interact with.
It's a way to interact with them from the
command line, which makes it useful for
doing things programmatically or if you
have big batch jobs, you want to upload a
bunch of items or modify the
metadata for a bunch of items.
It's also a Python library, which we won't
be getting too into for this session.
But the Python library is helpful for
developers who want to kind of build
tools to interact with the archive.
Anything from like, I know our tabletop
scribe uses it to upload books that are
scanned from the tabletop scribes.
The CD digitization project tool uses it,
all kinds of stuff.
And documentation is
available at the link below.
It's also in the thread for
the presentation in Slack.
And who is I for?
It's for everyone.
It's about 70% of all the items on archive.
org have been uploaded with either the
command line interface or the Python library.
And it's really easy to get started.
We make binaries for the
command line interface.
And that's just kind of like you can think
of it as like a script or just a file
you can download and you don't have
to install anything and you can start
using Ia right away.
So this first command up here
is just to download the file.
And then you need to make it
executable with this next line here.
And then you're ready to go.
You can run the last command there
just to kind of make sure you're up
to date on the latest version.
And this, the first command will actually
it will always download the latest
version of the tool.
So if you think you are out of date or
it's been a while since you downloaded a
new binary, you can just rerun that command
and you'll have the latest version.
And most commands in the command line tool
require configuration.
Not all of them, but if you want to upload
anything or write any metadata, even
search requires authorization.
So all you have to do is you just run
this Ia configure command and you enter
your email address associated with your
archive.org account and your password.
And it will go off and fetch all
of the cookies and authorization
stuff that you need to get started.
And so that's pretty much it.
Once you do that, you're ready to go.
This is just a screenshot of the I help menu.
You can see right here,
there's all of the commands that you can use.
Went through configure metadata.
It can be used to read and write metadata.
Upload is for uploading items or
files to items and creating items.
Downloads for downloading.
Delete, you can delete files with delete.
Search is for searching.
Tasks is an interface for the archive.
org catalog.
It can also be used to submit
tasks like derives or fixer tasks.
And then lists is just a way
to get an easy listing of
the files that are in a given item.
Copy is used to copy files from one item
to another or within the same item.
Move is the same.
It can be used to rename files or
move files from one item to another.
And reviews can be used to submit reviews.
That's used a lot in our 7-8-RPM project.
Brewster has a little dating
script that goes and tries to
find dates for the items.
And before we promote them to proper
metadata and metaxml, we'll submit them as
a review for people to look over
and make sure it looks good
before we put it into the metadata.
So, yeah, so it's helpful if you want to submit
reviews programmatically for any reason.
And then I'm just going to go over briefly
here just a couple of use cases that I
imagine this crowd might be
particularly interested in.
Or at least could kind of give you
an idea if the command line tool is
something that would be helpful to you.
So a lot of people who work with items
on archive.org often have to create
item lists for various reasons.
Search is a really easy way.
You can use the item list option here just
to create give an query, create a list
of items that you can be later used to
with many of our tools, either on the
website or running commands with the
command line tool, but just to get a group
of items that you want to operate on.
And of course,
downloading is probably one of the biggest
things the tool is used for.
There's a lot of different ways you can do it.
This is really handy if you just
want to download a collection or
a set of items matching a query.
Not really think about it too much.
You can just use the search option here
and then you just provided a query in
single quotes like that and it'll just
go through and download all the files.
And if you're downloading a big collection,
there's a good chance
that some of the requests might fail.
So when you're done, you can just rerun
the same command and it'll skip over any
files that have already been downloaded
and read, try to re-download
the failed downloads.
Okay, and then there's spreadsheet mode.
This is just an example of a spreadsheet
that can be used in spreadsheet mode.
And spreadsheet mode is an
option in upload and metadata.
So say you have a bunch of files that
you want to upload and you don't want to
write like a Python script to kind of
like do this programmatically and stuff.
What you can do is you
can create a spreadsheet.
And for upload, there's two required fields.
At least it's identifier and
this is the identifier for
your item that you're going to create.
And then file, which is just a path to the
file you'd like to upload to the item.
If you have multiple files, you can see here,
you just leave the next line blank
and I'm sorry, you actually,
this is a mistake on my part.
You should still put the identifier there,
but you can add
multiple files to an item like that.
And then any other columns you add to
the spreadsheet are just metadata keys
that you'd like to add to the item.
So you can add as many as you'd like.
You can add your own custom metadata
and it'll get added to the item.
Any fields that are like subject or if
there's multiple creators, you can add
them by doing a little index
at the end of the key.
So just like an open bracket and then
subject zero closed bracket and you can add
as many as you'd like and you can
leave them blank if not every item has
that field on it.
And then to run it, you just do I upload
dash s spreadsheet and then you point to
your spreadsheet and it'll go through
and it'll upload all the files.
And it's not in this example, but if there
were any failed uploads, you could add
a option to this command is just dash dash
checksum and this would skip over any
files that have already been uploaded
and just re upload the failed ones.
And now with that same spreadsheet,
you can use I metadata dash dash spreadsheet
point to the spreadsheet and this
will basically update the items.
On the spreadsheet with whatever
the metadata is in the spreadsheet.
So if you upload a bunch of files with
spreadsheet mode and then you realize, oh,
I screwed up by, you know, the creator
field or the collection field, you can
just go back to your spreadsheet modify
it and then run this command and
update all the metadata.
And that's kind of it for the brief overview.
There's documentation linked in the slack
thread. There's the the URL again. But,
um, yeah, that's just kind of like a
brief overview. If anybody has any
questions, that'd be a good time.
I have a super basic question just on the
last thing you mentioned about updating
metadata. So would you only
include a column of the updated
metadata? Would it be a problem if you,
you know, include all that
metadata that you already set?
Yep, no, you can you can just keep the
metadata that you already set there and
it'll just skip over it if it's the same.
Otherwise, it'll update it. Yeah.
I have a question concerning configuring
the tool for the first time access.
Yeah. I am log. I am registered on archive.
org using my archive.org account,
which itself which itself
is a Google apps account.
Yeah. So how can I link that with because
it asks for a password and I don't have
it and there is no password for that
account on there. Yeah, absolutely. So this
is a I forget when we've added support for
linking your using your Google account
to log into archive.org. But this is an
issue I've seen come up recently. And the
solution is to I forget exactly how you do it.
And I can follow up with you,
Kareem. But it's you have to go into the
archive.org like profile page and you
and Brendan might know to answer this,
but you basically have to like request a
password like say you forgot your password.
I think that's because I could yeah,
yeah, I'm the place to change it actually.
So yeah, yeah. And then whenever you
set the password there, then you just use
that password in your Google email to
continue. Great. Thank you. Yep.
Yeah. And so I think like with a
especially if you haven't really used the
command line much or if you
haven't used the I a tool.
There's a lot of different use cases.
So if you're if you do have any specific
projects where you think this could be useful,
but you're not quite sure how to
dive in, please reach out to me.
I'm super happy to help with
anything command line tool related.
But yeah, if you're working in bulk with items,
uploading, downloading, writing
metadata, reading metadata, it can be
super helpful. So if you haven't used it
before, and you're not even sure that it
seems like it's over your head. I don't
think it is. So yeah, please reach out and
we'll get you get you set up using it.
All right. Someone. Yes.
I was wondering this configuration
thing. What would be involved in making our
system so that we can have access tokens,
so we don't have
to provide username and password.
We can generate like multiple like
access tokens. Like I mean, we do it
on all those platforms, right?
Our username and password remains same
as it is. We may not even have one as
Kareem was mentioning, but we all can
request for like, you know, like an expire
it or remove it or, you know, disable it when.
Yeah, absolutely. So one thing that
the password isn't stored in your
configuration file is just used to retrieve it.
So if you do decide to revoke
your s3 keys later, or whatever,
your configuration file should be fine to
dispose of or whatever your password is
not in there, though your cookies are
currently, which is something we're
trying to move away from. That's a good
question. If you didn't want to provide
your password, you can one solution is
you can manually create the configuration file.
It's just an any file. It's
pretty basic. I think it might even be
documented. Yeah, so you could just go and
manually retrieve your your s3 keys if you
knew them and you could write the file
yourself. But yeah, if that's something
that you think would be useful, I imagine
it would we could add that pretty easily
where you could just provide your your
tokens and it would kind of create that.
So I asked that because more often than
not, I use this tool from Docker containers.
And I throw them away. So each time
I try to get a new Docker container,
unless I'm on my desktop, where I can mount
my home drive or something like that,
where the keys are in the right place, I
kind of have to go through the reconfigure
process each time, basically. And
yeah, that makes sense. I can just
provide it in an environment variable or
something like that,
whatever way I can bring that information
inside. And yeah, absolutely.
No, I hear you. That's a good use case.
I'll follow up with you and kind of
figure out what the best solution for that
might be. But yeah, we can definitely
make that use case easier for sure.
I think it is less about the tool,
but more about our authentication system at
the archive, internet archive
that needs to support this before
tool can adapt to it, I guess, right?
Yep, I think for yeah, and we can go
into more of this one on one, too. But I
think for your particular use case,
too, even I just like if you could just
provide the tool with your S3 keys,
and then the
tool could just write the config for you.
I might have missed something in the
initial presentation. We can upload
spreadsheets with information, metadata fields,
so on and so forth. Is it as easy
to download a spreadsheet with all the
relevant metadata for items on the set? Or
is that a slightly more advanced?
So are you suggesting you want to download like
a spreadsheet of the metadata or the items?
Okay. Yeah, there's
a pretty easy way to do that. It's not
all enclosed within the tool, but you can
use a tool called jq. I'm not sure if
you're familiar, but it's a command line
tool for parsing JSON. Yeah, so you can
use the I search command, which outputs
JSON. And I'll paste an example for you
in the thread once we're done here. But
yeah, there's a way to kind of shape
it and massage it into CSV from the
search command. Yep. Yeah. So right now,
basically, I use like if I'm going to
download an external or an outgoing manifest,
I will use I
believe one of the tools you already
have in there build manifest on PHP.
It's an old burger tool,
and just selected for like a ship track. Right.
And I don't know under certain circumstances,
I would replace that with the
command line tool functionality.
I am curious whether you think the command line
tool will be more efficient in generating
that outgoing manifest. It could be
I'm I'm familiar with the build
manifest PHP endpoint. But um, but
so I guess I'd be more interested
in hearing kind of like what the
inefficiencies with that are, to see if
like the command line tool could be more
useful. It off the top of my head,
you know, it's it could be helpful if it's
something that you wanted to automate.
Like if you had to build these manifests
like once a week, and it was kind of the
same query or something, you could set
up a reoccurring job to kind of just do
that for you automatically. But yeah, it
sounds like, you know, it could be
potentially useful. So I, yeah, be happy to
kind of reach out to you directly and kind
of try to figure out if that could be
something that could be helpful.
Thank you. Mm hmm.
Any other questions?
I guess I'll ask, you know,
a lot of time partners want to replace files.
Is there a special way to do that,
that it's replacing it instead
of just adding it to it?
Yeah. Yeah, you just upload the new file
with the same name as the old file to
the same item, and it'll just clogger it.
Thanks. Yep.
Yeah, well, um, so yeah, I was kind of
just wanted this to be a kind of brief
overview for folks who kind of heard
Jake's tool or about the command line
before, but didn't really kind of have a
good idea of what it is or what it could
do. But yeah, I hope it was informative
and kind of gave you an idea of, oh, this
is definitely for me or this is definitely
not for me. And yeah, again, I'm
really happy to work with anybody directly
on any specific projects they have and
any questions, either in command line tool,
gee, you can drop a message or feel
free to DM me as well. Whatever's easiest
for you. Hey, Jake, I had a quick
question, but thanks for this overview.
I am working with the Asian Art Museum.
It's a partner, and they're looking at
our collections, you know, being able to
gather. I'm looking at the metadata and
all of this information. They also would
like to download and maybe
create also a custom collection
with items on our collections,
but then add to it.
Okay. So this is a project that I
probably would like to work with
you and get more information on.
So this is something they want to create
for a number of their artists, but
there's a lot in our collections that they
want to gather and look at when you're
looking at all this metadata. So it's a
project that they're putting together. So
I guess I can reach out to you
more about it specifically.
Yeah. But you do create custom. I know that.
Yeah. Yeah, absolutely. Yeah. And
yeah, that invitation for helping with
the tool definitely extends to partners
and whoever. So please feel free to copy
me on any emails or introduce me to
anybody who needs help with it.
And it is something that we've worked with like
even just like a lot of librarians and
people who don't code or aren't super
technical, and they've had a lot of success
with it. We use it a lot for people
who come to us and we're doing like a data
exchange and they want us to download
a bunch of stuff for them, which we're
happy to do. But a lot of times we can
point them to the tool and then they can
do it themselves. And it saves kind of
everybody a lot of time too.
So yeah. I'm curious. Isa
asked in the chat what your favorite trick
or thing to do with the command line
tool is. Oh, shoot. That's all right.
Cool. Yeah, thanks for pointing that out.
My favorite trick or thing to do.
My favorite thing honestly is uploading
because like you can, you know,
I think I've uploaded over 2 million items now
and it's really fun when you get a new
collection and you just fire it off. The
RS3 API, it does get overloaded, but it's
with the way it's worked out where like
retries work, you can kind of just overload it.
It's not going to bring down the
site. Chances are it's not sometimes again.
But yeah, you can just kind of throw
everything at it and then leave and come
back and you see thousands of items that
were uploaded. Yeah, I think that's kind
of one of my favorite. Other favorite
ones are just like trying to
weed out or find items or files
based on metadata. You know,
like when search fails, like to be able to find
certain things. Yeah, it's fun using
something I didn't go into in this
presentation just because I didn't want
to overwhelm people with technical stuff,
scare them away. But I mentioned it before,
but JQ is a tool for parsing JSON and
a lot of the commands in the
tool will output JSON. So
coming up with JQ commands to kind of
like get the information you need and
reformat it. Yeah, I don't know.
I find that stuff kind of fun.
But also, I think just like the biggest
success for the tool for me has been kind
of making it easier for people who wouldn't
normally use or like write a Python
script to upload in bulk or something.
That's probably the most exciting kind of
thing that the tool serves for me.
So yeah, so also too, what the tool does, does
seem like something that'd be useful to you,
but it does kind of seem
overwhelming. I'd love to hear that too,
because yeah, I think personally, that's
kind of one of my primary goals with
the tool is to make it easier for non
-programmers and stuff to kind of do some
of these bigger jobs and whatnot. Jason?
Yeah, just wanted to pass along that I
live for this tool. This tool is the
central part of my life.
I'm doing tens of thousands of transactions
automatically with it every
single day without it.
The Internet Archive would have choked
on its incoming files years ago. I don't
think I'd still be in the same job.
So thanks for not just what you've done with
it, but for providing it for
things like the CSV tool and
retries and sleep, you know,
these critical aspects that make it possible.
And I get nothing but delight when I
interact with somebody who's staring at a
couple hundred thousand things to deal with,
and I tell them that there's this
command line tool. So thanks for your
tireless work on it, Jake. I know it eats
up. It's your master work at the archive.
So thanks for working on it.
Absolutely. Thank you for helping me
debug it over the years. Sawood, did you
have another question? Yeah, first I
wanted to share one of my favorite moments
with that tool. I was supporting a
researcher and I told them, go use
IATool and they came up with some question
like, hey, how I can download this
particular thing. And I was like, okay.
So I gave them two commands and I said,
hey, first run this command and save the
output in a file so that you kind of got
the list of things that you want to
download and then run this IAA download
command to download that. And then next
morning I saw this, I was reading the
documentation of IAA download and it was
a dash dash search and I was like, oh,
so I can combine the two things. Right.
So I posted them another method and I
said, hey, forget about what I said.
Here is a simple way. One
command, you can do this all together.
You know, that was a very delighting moment.
Yeah. But
one thing that kind of stuck with me,
I don't know if it is something that will
be worth adding to the tool. How others
feel about it is like sometimes I have
like a complex query, right? For example,
I have a requirement like go to this
collection or a bunch of collections and
go into them items and directories and
all those places and find anywhere
where there's a VAR file, there's
corresponding, you know, say a CDF file,
but not all CDF files are something that
I want.
I want to exclude some and I want to get some.
So you have like an interesting
pattern to put together
and then you perform the service, right?
Yeah. If there was a bookmarking mechanism
somewhere where I can have all these
queries, like, you know, save with my own
aliases somewhere and I can reuse them,
that would be awesome.
But right now I just use my history to kind
of, you know, go and find how I did that.
And then if I want to make any modifications,
learn it again. Yeah. You know,
some place like a stash place where you
can define your own patterns with some
given name and you reuse them,
something like that. Yeah. I really like that
idea. I'm not sure exactly, yeah,
like how that would work or kind of what the
solution would be. But I agree with you.
I think it's something I don't think of
actually a lot because yeah, I rely on
my just terminal history quite a bit to
kind of like recall queries and stuff.
Because yeah, they can definitely get
complex. But yeah, that's a really good
idea or kind of like if some way to
create like aliases for
certain queries or something.
That will make the IAC config file grow bigger,
right? Yeah. Yeah, interesting.
Yeah. And I'm always open to
feature requests too, if anybody
has. But yeah.
And thanks indeed for this amazing work.
Yeah. Well,
thanks for using it and for the feedback.
I appreciate it. Yeah. Well,
if nobody has any other questions, I'm always
around. So please reach out if
anything comes up or if you
do have any questions. Happy to help.
Yeah. I'll stick around if anybody does
have any more questions, feel free to
ask. But yeah, otherwise,
I think that's a wrap. Thanks
for coming, everybody. Yeah, thank you.
Thanks, Jake. Thanks, Jake.
I'm going to reach out. I have a little
project that I'm hoping to do.
Yeah, absolutely. Sounds great, Liz.
Thanks. Jake, I just
have one more question. Yeah, totally.
Which is like as a total beginner, Jake,
you I mean, you've given me so many
examples of like Jake Q operations.
And I would love to like learn it instead of
just having that ask you to. And I googled
and found a tutorial, but wondered if
you have any recommendations on Yeah,
so it's it's kind of like one of those
classic command line tools that I it sucks.
Like even people who are much
smarter than me at the archive, I was like,
Jake, how do I do this? Jake, you
command. It's I would Yeah, I would try
to like, you know, hone in on your like
specific use cases where you use Jake,
you and kind of just like learn how to do
it in those particular ways.
It does have good documentation, or thorough, I
should say, I don't know about good,
but it's that will kind of like try to
explain everything.
Yeah, the syntax is really weird.
It's for how it's like, it's a really
powerful tool, but it's, it's kind of
terse, you know what I mean? It can do a lot,
but it doesn't like do it like in
an easy way. So I don't really have
any good advice for kind of like, it's
something that honestly, like, I'm still
always like learning and forgetting and
kind of like having to refer back to
documentation when I'm doing more
complicated stuff. But um, but yeah,
I think maybe the best way to learn is just
anytime you need to use jq,
and you can't figure it out, shoot a message in
command line tool G, there's a lot of
other kind of jq connoisseurs there. So I,
yeah, I kind of just like asking and
asking the same questions again, and
relearning them I think is the best way
with jq. Okay, that's super affirming.
Thank you. Yeah. Thank you. Yeah.